[Applause]
hello I'm on the starter Kirk I remember
it so you don't have to I'm in a little
bit of a dilemma you see one of the
first videos I ever did arguably the
first video I ever did was a review of
Michael Bay's Transformers movie it was
similar to another character style so
start off like a copter was taken down
years ago
get out of copter I will shoot so we
keep going out this British girlfriend
who may or may not be dating the shmup
Foreman champion but as you can tell I
like it was stupid but it's a guilty
pleasure I can't help what I like but
over the years this tradition kind of
started where I would always review a
Transformers movie whenever it came out
usually resulting in a crossover with
that character but here's the thing as
they kept going to review style mattered
less because I was running out of things
to say mostly because the movies are
running out of things to say every
single time while these damn fields came
out they just did the same thing over
and over and over and and what am I
supposed to say oh that happen again
that happened together there's no
variety as the reviews on the movie
continued I got more and more angry
because I just didn't have much left
what was I supposed to say to this
lazily written creatively empty
franchise Michael Bay himself came out
saying you can complain about it all you
want but you'll still go see it I don't
want give money to that idea the idea
that someone can just keep putting out
the exact same crap but we're too
conditioned to break away look I have
the Great Lord ready as a luxury of
being one of the few critics who doesn't
have to see movies every weekend I only
see movies I feel are worth talking
about whether good or bad they actually
have some relevance they can have some
meaning they can have something we can
learn from but honestly I feel like I've
talked about all I can with this series
it's just constant repeat with little to
nothing added I want to push for more
original and challenging material I do
not support this shit like he predicted
I will humming was going on and on how
their shitty reboots aren't making that
much money not because their shitty
boots but because there's something
wrong with us no there's something wrong
with you you keep doing the same thing
over and over and we need new stuff but
this series for whatever reason is never
affected they always make tons and tons
of money I don't want to review these
movies anymore because I don't think
there's anything new left to review but
I also have a tradition I always review
this shit even though in my opinion
there's nothing new to review it's just
the first film - any surprises like all
the other sequels were so what to do
I am so convinced that this movie is
going to be the exact same goddamn
formula that all the other movies have
been that I am actually going to review
it without seeing it it is so tired and
repetitive that I'm pretty sure I can
predict the piece of crap movie I would
have suffered through that's how bad
things have gotten it might be off by
detail or - but I'm sure I can still
tell you what's going to happen now you
can be saviors oh man rightfully so that
doesn't seem very fair you can't judge a
movie without actually seeing it so I
guess look at this less as a review and
more as a artistic experiment an
experiment to see if Hollywood can
really be so unimaginative and lazy and
yet we keep somehow still falling for it
seeing if the rats will ever stop
running through the maze with no reward
maybe don't believe me you think I'm
lying that I actually did see this movie
and I'm just telling you what I saw go
ahead won't be the first time someone
didn't believe somebody on the internet
but I can feeling if we measure both our
brain cells mine are going to be the
exact same amount and yours are going to
be less after saying that that moving
and the funny thing is I actually hope
I'm wrong I hope I am wrong about
everything I'm about to say I hope that
somebody who worked on this film finally
said let's give some variety something
new something they haven't seen before
let's finally take our audience like
intelligent human beings but my guess is
this is what we're going to get
it's going to start off years and years
ago in the past you think oh this is
what the movie is going to be about
transformers with knives and Nazis and
catapult inflames but it's not it's more
the same just transformers fighting in
modern day in the city and or desert all
this stuff with an ice and Nazis that
they're showing all over the trailer
that's going to be in the first few
minutes but probably a little flashback
to it in the middle because you know I
see transformers fighting with knife
even though it's called the last night
oh wait yes you do what you're not going
to get it because you need American Mick
American played by Mark Wahlberg from
the last movie because he's the new main
character we'll have some sort of
introduction with him getting used to
the Transformers as every day why you
pleading to comedy that's not funny
but it's big so your testicle to be like
that's funny cuz it's big don't worry
you also get small annoying comedic
moments with obnoxious comedy relief you
pray to Christ they're not going to be
in a lot of the film but they probably
are making dumb sex jokes to the first
graders that shouldn't be watching this
movie but clearly this is the exact
audience the film is made for speaking
of which we got set up our supporting
cast which is usually kids whether high
school college or even younger
we need a good-looking kid who for some
reason is an outcast even though they
could probably get by in their looks
alone if it's a boy he'll be awkward and
funny if it's a girl it will be a bad
attack we need the geek or geeks one of
them will probably die because we only
need one thing unfunny awkward dialogue
and of course we need the hot chick
who's also a brain and they'll
demonstrate this by giving her glass
she's supposed to be smarter than
everyone else but clearly she spent more
time trying to get her makeup right in
her computer-savvy dialogue we need of
course returning supporting Cathy to
jock Janelle John Turturro Stanley Tucci
or if they're really desperate all of
them even a Shia cameo if they're beyond
desperate you need the celebrity suit
this is a person that looks really
important to the story but they're not
they're just there to read exposition
they get a baked into five star to make
you think there's a lot of weight to
this role but usually they do something
really stupid that you're supposed to
think it's funny because it's that
dignified star looking like a
two-year-old but it's not funny it's
just that dignified star looking like a
two-year-old
and a dignified star does it without
question because and I don't grandkids
like these movies
oh and the suit is covering up something
because the person in a suit is always a
big part of the government cover-up that
somehow nobody ever figures out just by
sir apparently being millions of times
the Transformers and pretty much created
our history
hell even some of the city fights in the
other films were somehow covered up and
even the government would be stupid
enough to tell us not to trust our own
eyes and ear they actually attack
Department Optimus Prime who's always
the biggest one on the poster once again
won't be the main lead and will again be
the human characters even though the
movies not called humans he'll be out of
commission a good chunk of the movie
either hiding or looking for something
if these in space he's probably looking
for someone or something from his
homeworld because to decide I love
students and bad sequels but some evil
force comes along this after some power
energy thing yes there's always some
power energy thing it's very vague and
how it works but Webber has it can do
some big damage the big threat will be
Megatron though because we love having
the Transformers biggest villain in most
of these movies without having him in
most of the movie he'll still be a
nuisance but only second banana to the
big bad alien Dylan is the big bad alien
villain a slimy creature an orb of Lies
or some sort of evil creature that's on
par with HR Deidre's designs no it's
just another human looking machine
that's riding a giant ship or metal
device that's going to blow up
everything oh and it has to do something
on the moon because for some reason
Michael Bay is really obsessed with the
moment I think it's fine but oops with
every passing movie they want make
Optimus Prime more and more badass so
they make a meaner and meaner so the
time around will probably go all the way
and make you think he's a bad guy
because when a series runs out of theme
that's a twist they always think we fall
for they'll even have some big fight
with his best friend and he does be
unthinkable by beating the shit out of
him or even nearly killing their God try
and make it look like the friend is dead
but he's not it's another fake out like
when Optimus died because they didn't
have the balls at a Saturday morning
cartoon had so does this meet Optimus
Prime is now a full-on villain
destroying years of hero worship and the
ultimate franchise gamble yes
yes it is and Mickey Mouse is officially
going to become a terrorist of course
that doesn't happen
he's either brainwashed or controlled by
the villain but the figure out a way to
making things straight and he'll be good
once more but after we have several
scenes of asking me of humanity's worth
it because you know it was so deep the
other four times we did Charlie this
time you won't forget this'll result in
a lot of slo-mo a lot of explosions you
won't even flinch at any more because
you've gotten so used to them a
situation where a hot guy flexes his
muscles a situation where a hot woman
does something sexy something so
outdated ly unfunny that will offend you
on either a racial sexual or even just
kindergarten level and all that action
you think is going to be amazing and
will throw a lot of money into you're
not going to be able to really enjoy
because you know that Michael Bay he's
an artist so he has to shoot the action
sequences from different angles than
what you're used to the problem is he's
not a very good artist
so it's either an angle that so close
you can't make out most of the action so
cluttered you can't make out most of the
action or edited so fast that you can't
make out most of the action even if you
see it in 3d with all the slo-mo yeah
that great chart is really going to look
different from the rest of the great
chart but it's okay because you'll have
two even three legitimately cool action
moments but only a few seconds long but
you can actually see them so you'll
choose to find it cool you waited almost
three hours of the exact same shit
you've seen over and over to put that
two minutes of actual good action
somehow you'll justify in your head was
completely worth it in the end the main
human characters will learn something
about letting go yet somehow being
closer Optimus Prime will make the same
big speech that's trying to sound deep
but it's really just a long-winded way
of saying we rock the bad guy will be
destroyed but some villainous element
usually Megatron will escape for a
sequel and even though every story every
setup every bit of advertising is trying
to make it look like this is going to be
the last one its cover the last one the
last night is not the last film the age
of extinction has nothing becoming
extinct The Revenge of the Fallen
doesn't really last there's always
always more and if you keep thinking
over and over that this is going to be
the
I gotta be more so what do you think was
I close maybe maybe not maybe this is
the one that's going to break the mold
maybe this will be the one that takes it
in a brand new direction with twists and
turns they're legitimately surprising
but as the famous business model go if
it's broken but makes a lot of money why
fix it
my guess is this is the same movie
they've shown us four times already and
here's the thing if you like this fine
it can't help what you like hell I enjoy
the first one despite it being so stupid
but with so many films repeating the
same thing over and over and those still
not doing as well as the studio's want
remember you have the right to demand
better you're the right to say if I'm
going to see something I'm already
familiar with I can at least a man to
see something new with it you can be
fine with the same old crap but you can
demand smarter and more exciting crap we
all have that fast boom McDonald's
garbage that we eat but even McDonald's
put out a new sandwich every once in a
while you don't have to eat a shitty
cheeseburger over and over and over you
can demand a new sauce a new meal he was
a new restaurant but the rodeo burger is
still amazing this is just a different
take on a fascinatingly repetitive
series and I don't see myself doing it
often or really ever again I'm a
reviewer I want to talk about what I see
as opposed to what I don't see this is
just something dick like I said an
artistic experience something I don't
think we'll ever see the transformer
movies trying anytime soon but the one
thing I want you to take away from this
whether I'm right about most of this
stuff or not is that if you're not going
to demand something good you can at
least demand something too I might've
stodger it I remember it
whether you've seen it or not
[Music]
[Applause]
you